viruses come in many shapes and sizes
ranging from simple protein shells
filled with RNA or DNA to membrane
envelope particles that rival cells in
complexity
HIV is one of those complex viruses
surrounded by a membrane and filled with
a diverse collection of viral and
cellular molecule the genome of HIV
which is composed of two strands of RNA
it's packaged inside a distinctive
cone-shaped capsid which protects the
RNA and delivers it to the cells that
HIV infects
before you begin building the HIV capsid
make sure you have the template scissors
and tape to model the genome you could
use two pieces of string each three
point three meters long step 1 cut out
the model leaving the gray tabs intact
step 2 fold along the white line for a
rounder model that is closer to the
shape of the actual capsid try
assembling the model without this step
step3 tape or glue the gray flaps taping
on the inside and outside will make the
model more stable
step four at this point
insert two pieces of string to represent
the two RNA strands each of them should
be three point three meters long step 5
now you can close your model of the HIV
capsid
for more information about the HIV
capsid and the HIV related proteins and
activities visit the RCS BPD b101
website at our CSP org slash pdb 101